hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in the course of
his discussions about friendship in book
eight of the Nicomachean ethics after
talking about three main types of equal
friendships that is friendships in which
both partners are friends with the other
person on the basis of some good weather
it be virtue or pleasure or usefulness
Aristotle is also going to talk about
what are called unequal or sometimes
called mixed friendships where the
relationship is not quite so reciprocal
is that and one of the key issues that
that arises with that is how to make
those sorts of relationships work well
by making sure that there's some sort of
equality between the friends maintained
because these friendships have to be
regulated by some kind of
proportionality and as we'll see so he
talks about several types of unequal
friendships not all in the same place in
the text by the way the first type that
he actually brings up is when there's
what we might call power or differences
power differences or rulership
differences differentials between who is
actually in charge and as we we know
from some of the other
which I've covered in other videos
familial relations often have a sort of
natural basis for this but he talks also
about rulers and subjects we might also
think in terms of superiors and
subordinates within an organization you
know we could come up with all sorts of
examples you know say the captain of a
team or a team leader who is assigned to
do you know a particular project or
something like that in that case
Aristotle says that there is a
relationship there there is a friendship
and it's one that is going to be by its
very nature unequal Aristotle doesn't
think that parents are on the same level
as children and there can even be
differentials between elder siblings and
younger siblings he also talks about
friends who are friends with each other
on the different basis or in in
respective different cuts so it may be
difficult for a person who is genuinely
virtuous to find another virtuous person
to be friends with you know that takes a
long time to cultivate that but that's
not to say that the virtuous person
can't be loved you know felt affection
towards whatever else we want to think
about in this case by other people who
don't possess virtue but bring something
else to the table it could be that they
bring pleasure so we could have a a
virtuous person and people are friends
with them because this person is a
genuinely good person but the other
people who are not genuinely good people
are at least pleasant you know they they
engage in some activities together that
they both find pleasant perhaps the the
pleasant person is witty Aristotle likes
to use that as an example there's also
possibilities for the virtuous person
they have relationships with other
people where the the other person really
only has
utility to contribute usefulness in some
way they make contacts for them they
invite them to the parties but they
invite them to the parties precisely
because they want somebody there who is
a genuinely good person and because
people like to spend time with people
like that a third possibility of an
imbalance of this sort would be
relationships in which one person is
contributing pleasure and the other
person is contributing usefulness so
people who are pleasant get invited to
parties you know the person who has the
party is the one who is providing the
usefulness in that case the food the
drink the opportunities the the music
whatever it is and the person who's
pleasant comes along for the ride and
they get invited precisely because they
are providing other people with with
pleasure so we can imagine many
relationships of this sort I think a lot
of romantic relationships people would
like to think that they're different
than they are but they can be exchanges
where one person is providing pleasure
the other person is providing some other
kinds of benefits we often you know make
jokes about this sort of thing when we
see that going on we say that somebody's
truly out of the other person's lead
what is she doing with him what is he
doing with her those would be examples
of that sort of exchange another
possibility that Aristotle talks about
is when the friends are friends on the
same basis so in terms of the same
fundamental good of virtue or pleasure
or usefulness but they vary from each
other in the amount that they provide so
it could be to take pleasure for for an
example they have to people really are
pleasant for each other but one person
provides much more pleasure for the
other person then the other person
provides for them sometimes romantic or
erotic relationships are like that but
we could also think of that in terms
friends who you know joke around with
each other friends who participate in
sports together you know all sorts of
other possibilities it's the same thing
for usefulness friends can be more or
less useful to each other this can also
change from situation or time or even
you might say culture you know now that
we can travel around and place ourselves
in different contexts
there could be an imbalance there right
one person could be much more useful to
the other person than the other person
is to them we could even have this in
terms of virtue or you know moral
goodness within a person one person
might be much much better than the other
person perhaps the other person was just
starting out on the path to virtue
doesn't really have it all together the
other person really does have it all
together
and maybe it's even like a mentoring
relationship or or you know something
along those lines
another thing that never stumble does
talk about he mentions very briefly
something like you know wisdom you know
not wisdom in the practical sense but in
a speculative sense it could be that one
person is friends with another person
because that person is very very smart
and is able to you know convey knowledge
to them and that could also fit into
this differing basis but that could fit
into the same level we don't always have
people who have developed their
intellectual resources to the same
degree but they can be friends with each
other and the key has you to hear that
like I said it is well what equalizes
the unequal
why is this important well the Harris
house says in terms of utility if one
person is putting in a lot and the other
person is not putting in much at all
that looks more like a charity case and
much less like a friendship and I think
we could say similar things in terms of
pleasure or or in terms of virtue as
well now to mention the the mixed
friendships
so what equalizes things what actually
makes it possible for the people to feel
like it's fair
like it makes sense like everybody is
getting something good out of it the
both people are better off in their
relationship than they are outside the
relationship so Aristotle suggests that
affection and when we talk about a
fashion here we're actually talking
about that verb feeling to feel
affection towards the other person or
feel a sigh that is to have affection
directed towards you and Aristotle says
then the person who is superior in the
unequal relationship should get more of
the affection that is they should have
affection to felt more strongly towards
them or displayed more strongly towards
them by the person who is inferior in
the friendship because the that's the
only thing that the the only person can
really give it back they they can't give
them something that's useful right they
can't give them something that's nearly
Pleasant and they don't have virtue to
provide them with but they can at least
feel affection display affection to talk
about it
another thing the nearest level is going
to talk about you a little bit later is
honor honor is you know sort of a public
show of respect I think that we could
probably place people talk in terms of
gratitude
we could probably place displays of
gratitude under that of Honor as well
there's some sort of you know showing
forth that the person is indeed grateful
you're grateful for what somebody else
has has provided you with so honor and
affection those are things that can you
know you might say rebalance the scale
so it's not so imbalanced and one of the
things that we all have to think about
is what else could possibly fit in here
as ways of making things equal I'm not
sure that within the Aristotelian scheme
there are any answers to that but but
there are possibilities perhaps for us
but we want to be careful that they
don't simply then reduce the honor
perfectly fine aerosol specs that's a
great way to equalize it or to affection
so these unequal friendships are very
important many of the friendships that
we are in and particularly the
friendships that we develop ourselves
within will turn out to be unequal
friendships so it's quite important to
keep this this key idea that are the key
question in mind